[Music]  same device  saying hello  you think your wife can hear you no  no don't wipe on  Maybe I'm Wrong  I'm going to die  maybe not goodbye to you my trusted  friend  a new day is Dawning  new ideas no wounds  New Management we've known each other  since  [Music]  who is this  challenge him to single combat with a  loose it's a way out  I don't sit at the table your family  does please pray for me  [Music]  man has to look his best when it's time  to get married  or buried  I'm going to need a gun  by my friend  [Music]  if you win  the table will honor its word  we'll have your freedom  under the old laws only one can survive  to meet at Sunrise  a result an execution  Last Words Winston just have fun out  there  [Music]  I want you to find your peace but a good  death  only comes after a good life  you and I left a good life behind a long  time ago my friend  [Music]